At the end of WW1, one of the new countries that
emerged from the ashes of the Austro-Hungarian
Empire was Czechoslovakia. The way this
happened was extremely complicated, so if
you want to know the background to this history
go watch my breakup of Austria-Hungary videos
and my making of a Czechoslovak state video.
This new country of Czechoslovakia was quite
multiethnic but more importantly for this
video, it had a very sizable German minority
that had lived alongside the Czechoslovaks
in the Crownlands of Bohemia and Northern
Hungary for centuries. However, today there are
almost no German speakers to be found in Czechia
or Slovakia, so what happened to the roughly 3.2
million Germans of Czechoslovakia? Let’s find out.
This video is part of a greater collaboration with
other historytubers called Project Homecoming 2,
where everyone makes a history video about
a place where they’re from or where they
live or lived. So after this video go
check out all the other historytuber
videos link to the collab playlist is in
the description and the pinned comment.
In the 1920s, once the dust from
the breakup of Austria-Hungary had
settled and Czechoslovakia had firmly been
established as a country in Central Europe,
the new state had one major glaring problem.
Its multiethnic character. Well, at least
that’s how some parts of the population saw it.
In reality, talking about some unified German,
Czechoslovak, or even Ruthenian fronts in
Czechoslovakia would be very inaccurate.
Movements within these ethnic groups may have seen
themselves as similar in language and culture,
but politically the Germans were just as divided
as the Czechoslovaks or Ruthenians. Issues of
ethnic sovereignty were as much debated as ideas
of socialism, republicanism, authoritarianism,
etc. In essence, the ethnic strife between the
various ‘nations’ within Czechoslovakia was
certainly a point of contention, but it wasn’t the
only point of contention. In fact, to some people,
like socialists and communists, it wasn’t even the
most important point of contention. For example,
in the 1920 election, the Hungarian-German Social
Democratic Party, which already had Hungarians and
Germans in it, ran on a joint ticket with the
Czechoslovak Social Democratic Workers Party,
which was the largest political party in
Czechoslovakia at the time. During their political
campaign in Bratislava, their banners had three
different languages on them, all with various
socialist slogans like ‘death to the profiteers’.
At the same time, the Magyar-German pro-communist
labour conference in Košice called for the
interethnic unity of all Czechoslovak workers.
Clearly, to some politicians and voters in
early Czechoslovakia, the ethnic problem
wasn’t that relevant. Their perceived economic,
social and class struggles were, for them,
the priority. However, some doesn’t mean all, and
considering that ethnocentric nationalism was at
the heart of Czechoslovakia’s push for national
sovereignty after WW1, it would be far-fetched
to think that ethnic tensions weren’t dominant in
interwar Czechoslovakia. And, it’s these ethnic
tensions that eventually lead to ‘one of the
largest waves of forced migration in history’.
In this video, I will discuss the 20th-century
history of only Czechoslovak Germans because
their history differs from that of other minority
groups of Czechoslovakia, like Hungarians and
Ruthenians. Perhaps I will discuss them in another
video in the future. I will also talk about the
Czechoslovaks in the interwar period as one single
national group because most (but not all) official
Czechoslovak statistics and documentation of
the time didn’t differentiate between Czechs
and Slovaks, and, for the most part, in the first
Czechoslovak Republic, the Czechs and Slovaks were
classified as one single nation composed of two
national subgroups. The Slovak Declaration of
Independence in Martin even explicitly stated
it. Plus, except for a brief period during WW2,
everything in this video was done equally
by both the Czechs and the Slovaks.
--------------------------Forming an Accord
in the New State------------------------
In 1918, when the fate and exact borders
of the new country were still uncertain,
most German-speaking towns within the historical
borders of the Bohemian Kingdom and Northern
Hungary declared themselves independent and
worked towards joining either Austria, Germany,
or Hungary. The Zipser Saxons of today’s Spiš
region of Slovakia declared independence and
unification with Hungary, the Germans and
Hungarians of Pressburg declared the city
independent and neutral, and the various Sudeten
Germans declared independence and unification with
either Austria or Germany. In fact, in the brief
moment when Austria-Hungary had fallen apart,
but Germany had still not surrendered, there
existed German-sponsored bases all around
Czechoslovakia where radical Czechoslovak Germans
were armed and trained to fight the fledgling
Czechoslovak government. In the end, however,
Germany, Austria, and Hungary failed in contesting
the Czechoslovak takeover of the German-majority
populated areas allocated to it in the Paris peace
conference. This success of Czechoslovakia in
taking over the majority of German-speaking land
can be primarily attributed to Entente support
and the fact that most Germans in Czechoslovakia
had extreme war weariness after WW1 and promoted
peaceful resistance rather than a military one.
That is why despite the anti-Czechoslovak
sentiments in many of the German-majority
areas of Czechoslovakia, the takeover of those
areas by Czechoslovak troops was largely peaceful
in terms of human cost. Apart from riots and a
couple of deaths here and there due to attacks
by more radical Germans and Czechoslovaks, there
was only one major violent clash between the two
groups. Well, I say ‘clash between the two
groups’, but in reality, it was very much
a one-sided affair. Shortly after Czechoslovak
troops fully occupied the Sudeten German area,
a protest was scheduled by the Germans on
March 4th 1919, across the various Sudeten
German towns and villages. The Sudeten Germans
were demanding a vote for self-determination.
The protesters were unarmed, but as already
discussed, some radicalised Germans conducted
‘semi-military kind’ activities in the
area and some Czechoslovak soldiers,
fearing the protesters might have weapons, opened
fire in several towns and villages. In total,
54 German protesters were killed and 84
wounded. This event was no doubt a tragedy,
but it paled in comparison to other very bloody
battles happening all across the former lands
of Austria-Hungary, in Slovakia, in Poland,
in Slovenia, etc. In fact, the occupation
of German-majority areas by Czechoslovak troops
can be considered fairly peaceful on both sides.
The fairly peaceful occupation of the
majority German-populated areas is one thing,
but why was Czechoslovakia even given the majority
German areas in the Paris peace conference? Well,
as always, there are multiple reasons
for it, but the simplified version is:
First, Czechoslovakia was allied
with the Entente during the war.
Czechoslovak legions fought on the
side of the Entente in the war. Hence,
just like France got the German majority
Alsace–Lorraine and Italy got the German
majority Southern Tyrol, Czechoslovakia got
some German-majority parts of Austria-Hungary.
Second, the Czechoslovak movement was very
adamant about preserving the historical
lands of the Bohemian Crown. The Czechoslovaks
saw all the Bohemian Crown lands as rightfully
theirs regardless of whether more Germans
than Czechoslovaks currently populated
some parts of it. The Czechoslovaks
saw the Germans as just immigrants
or colonisers of a land which has always
been rightfully owned by the Czechoslovaks.
Third, the Entente, especially the French, didn’t
want to create a country that would be too small
and fragile and, therefore, incapable of defending
itself against possible future German, Austrian,
Hungarian, or Soviet aggression. In the eyes
of the Entente, either you made an economically
robust country with strong natural borders,
or you might as well not make a new country at
all because it would just fall to its stronger
neighbours. This is why industrially important
areas like northern Bohemia or strategically
important waterways, like the Danube River,
were given to Czechoslovakia despite these areas
having a majority non-Czechoslovak populations.
These were the main reasons why the
majority German-speaking areas were given
to Czechoslovakia in the Paris peace conference.
How was Czechoslovakia to deal with such a large
German minority was a matter of debate
in the Czechoslovak political circles.
For example, when the first prime minister
of Czechoslovakia, Karel Kramář, learned of
some Czechoslovaks violently taking down German
signs and inscriptions in the aftermath of the
Declaration of Independence, he stated that ‘I
believe it is our duty to say to ourselves that
every emphatic insistence upon our victory is
a sin against the future of our state. We must
at last learn consideration for the psychology
of the German people … I am profoundly ashamed
when I discovered that German inscriptions are
torn down in a German town.’ At the same time,
however, some Czechoslovak leaders like
Alois Rašín were far less sympathetic,
stating that ‘If the Germans insisted upon
having their own independent government’
like they did when they called for a vote
of self-determination ‘then the Czech must
direct their policy in accordance with the old
principle: no negotiations with the rebels!’.
With that said, Rašín style views were largely in
the minority, and ‘officially there was an effort
to follow from [Czechoslovak] politicians
rejecting chauvinism’. That is why Masarik,
and Benes offered to collaborate with
the German and Hungarian minority
parties (for example, like the German Social
Democratic Workers’ Party) in the writing of
the Czechoslovak constitution. But, the leaders
of the minority parties refused this offer and, in
protest of not being allowed self-determination,
boycotted the Constituent Assembly. What the
various German factions actually wanted when
they called for, quote, ‘self-determination’
was quite varied. Some wanted to unite with
Germany, others with Austria or Hungary,
some wanted to be completely independent, and some
wanted federal autonomy within Czechoslovakia,
and as Wiskemann points out, ‘it would be
impossible to estimate proportions’ of which
of these solutions were the most popular. He
continues to say that this disunity should not
be surprising as ‘The three million Germans who
now found themselves to be citizens of the new
Czechoslovak Republic had surprisingly little
in common until they became members of the same
so-called minority.’ The terms Sudeten Germans,
referring to the German-speaking population of
Czechia, and Carpathian Germans, referring to
the German-speaking population of Slovakia,
weren’t even used in their current definition
before the formation of Czechoslovakia.
However, for now, even though disagreeing on what
the ‘self-determination’ vote should be about,
the various German factions could at least agree
on the boycott of the Constituent Assembly. This
meant that the constitution of Czechoslovakia
was written without German or Hungarian input.
After the first parliamentary election in 1920,
in which 6 competing German political parties
won 26% of the seats, the German parties finally
showed up to the parliament where they vehemently
complained against the constitution,
which quote ‘had been forced upon them’,
despite the fact that they refused to collaborate
in its writing when specifically offered to.
The primary point of contention for the
Germans was Article 6 of the constitution,
devoted to the Protection of National,
Religious and Racial Minorities.
Its first clause stated that ‘All citizens of the
Czechoslovak Republic shall be in all respects
equal before the law and shall enjoy equal civic
and political rights whatever be their race,
their language or their religion … Difference in
religion, belief, confession or language shall
within the limits of the common law constitute
no obstacle to any citizen of the Czechoslovak
Republic particularly in regard of entry into
the public services and offices, of attainment
to any promotion or dignity, or in regard to the
exercise of any trade or calling.’ Also, ‘In towns
and districts in which there lives a considerable
fraction (20%) of Czechoslovak citizens speaking
a language other than Czechoslovak, the children
of such Czechoslovak citizens shall, in public
instruction and within the bounds of the general
regulations relating thereto, be guaranteed a due
opportunity to receive instruction in their own
tongue.’ All deputies of the parliament also had
the right to speak in their native language in
parliament, all official Government documents,
including currency, will have 4 languages on it
(Czechoslovak, Hungarian, Ruthenian, and German),
and lastly, ‘Every manner whatsoever of
forcible denationalisation is prohibited;
Non-observance of this principle may be
proclaimed by law to be a pu­nishable act.’
Historian Jan Kuklík, in his book Minorities and
Law in Czechoslovakia, deems the Czechoslovak
Constitution ‘rather temperate and fair from
the point of view of minorities.’ In fact,
the Czechoslovak constitution was one
of the most progressive on the continent
in terms of minority rights, especially
when compared to countries like France.
So what were the Germans complaining about? Well,
the 20% mark meant that towns and villages which
had a German population of 19.9% would not have
the legal right to public instruction in their
own language, nor would the government offices
and courts in those towns and villages have to
allow the use of another language other than
Czechoslovak in their proceedings. This meant
that towns and villages with less than 20% German
population would undergo Czechoslovakization. The
ironic part was that the 20% mark wasn’t
made up by the Czechoslovak government.
It was inherited from the Austro-Hungarian
system. One can’t help but spot the hypocrisy,
20% was good enough in the Austro-Hungarian
system when German and Hungarian were the
official languages, but it was suddenly too high
when Czechoslovak was the official language.
Historian Carlile Macartney aptly summarised
the situation by stating, ‘equality would not
have satisfied the Magyars and Germans, [who
have been] costumed so long to domination.’
It also must be stressed that the Paris
peace treaties explicitly stated that
there must be favourable minority laws in the
post-Austro-Hungarian countries. Otherwise,
the Entente would not support their creation.
However, considering most leading Czechoslovak
politicians of the time were not of a very
chauvinistic character, the minority laws would
have probably been written the same whether the
Entente enforced them or not. Most Czechoslovak
politicians were not blind to the fact that a
large part of their new country’s population were
minorities, and they knew antagonising them would
only lead to more problems and instability. That
is why initially, despite what the harrumphing
of the Germans and Hungarians in the parliament
might make you believe, the Czechoslovak
state was quite lenient towards minorities.
The most ardent proponent of such leniency was
none other than the first Czechoslovak president
Tomáš Masaryk. Himself of multiethnic origin,
Masaryk never really agreed with the idea of an
ethnostate. He believed the idea of ethnicity or
a ‘nation group’ should be separate from the idea
of a state, a country. One is a sense of social
identity, the other is a form of government in
a particular terriotiry, and in Masaryk’s eyes,
these should not be treated as the same. Masaryk
was a classicist at heart, and he often echoed
Cicero’s idea of a ‘nation’. According to Cicero
‘a nation is not any collection of human
beings brought together in any sort of way,
but an assemblage of people in large numbers
associated in an agreement with respect to
justice and a partnership for the common
good.’ Austria-Hungary had proved not to
be a ‘partnership’ for ‘justice’ and
‘common good’ for all its citizens,
but Czechoslovakia will … well, at least,
that’s what Masaryk hoped. It was, therefore,
with this mindset that Masaryk pardoned
the Germans and Hungarians who took up arms
against Czechoslovakia during the turbulent
break up of Austria-Hungary, it was with this
mindset that he argued for lenient minority
laws in the writing of the constitution,
and it was with this mindset that Masaryk tried
to govern the country during his presidency.
However, not everyone shared Masaryk’s
ideals, and Czechoslovakia had plenty of
nationalists unwilling to give ground to the
Germans or other minorities. In the 1920s,
despite the existence of minority laws,
some Czechoslovaks sought to skirt the law
wherever they could. For example, building new
Czechoslovak schools in German speaking areas
was interestingly always approved faster
than building new German schools. Also,
if German-speaking officials wanted to work
in a predominantly Czechoslovak-speaking area,
they had to take a test in Czechoslovak,
while Czechoslovak officials wanting to
work in a predominantly German-speaking area
had to declare they knew German but were never
tested on it. These mandatory Czechoslovak tests
for German officials working in predominantly
Czechoslovak-speaking areas resulted in the
firing of 33,000 German officials, while the
Czechoslovak officials deemed not to know German
usually just got reassigned to a different
area. Such leniencies to Czechoslovak-speaking
people, which were technically never breaking
the law but could hardly be called equal,
were present everywhere in the country.
Therefore, it should not be surprising that
‘During the interwar period, many petitions
were filed against Czechoslovakia with the League
of Nations, usually by the German and to lesser
extend also by the Hungarian minority. A
greater part of them claimed breaches of
the Minorities Treaty in connection with
the Czechoslovak Constitution’. However,
the League of Nations never
found any major breaches.
With that said, the 1920s, in general, could
be called a time of accord in Czechoslovakia
as the minority parties eventually
accepted they wouldn’t get their vote
of self-determination and started to work with
the institutions of their new country. In fact,
some German parties even formed political
coalitions with Czechoslovak parties and had
ministers in government (Bund der Landwirte
and German Christian Social People’s Party).
While the 1920s could be called a
time of accord in Czechoslovakia,
the 1930s were far from it; the
1930s were a time of division.
--------------------------
Nationalsozialismus------------------------
At the end of WW1, the German
National Socialist Workers’
Party (in Austria), also known as the
Nazis for short, was created in Vienna,
formed by the former members of the German
Workers Party (in Austria). The Nazi party
was inspired by Austro-Hungarian politicians
Karl Hermann Wolf and George von Schonerer,
who were part of the late 19th-century and
early 20th-century Pan-German Union, which was a
coalition party (Also known as the German-National
Association) in Austria. Pan-German Union split
into multiple groups, the most notable of which
was the German Workers Party (in Austria), founded
in Bohemia, from which the aforementioned
German National Socialist Workers’ Party,
or the Nazis for short, was created. The Nazis
were later forced to split into two parties due
to the breakup of Austria-Hungary, the Austrian
Nazi Party and the Czechoslovak Nazi Party.
Another person who was inspired by Karl Hermann
Wolf, George von Schonerer and their Pan-German
Union was Adolf Hitler. He himself joined the
German Workers Party in Germany and pushed
for its renaming to the National Socialist
German Workers’ Party, also known as Nazis
for short. In fact, when the German Nazi party
was effectively founded by its renaming in 1920,
the Czechoslovak Nazis and the Austrian Nazis were
so delighted they sent letters of congratulation
to the new Munich-based party, and they all
organised a Nazi congress in Salzburg that
same year. As you may have guessed, all these
parties, including the older Austrian ones,
were anti-Semitic, anti-democratic,
far-right racist, pan-German parties.
An interesting side note here. The
original German Workers Party in Austria,
from which the later Nazi parties formed, was
founded in Bohemia during the Austro-Hungarian
empire as a radical far-right German
response to the demands of the Czechs
for more autonomy and more minority rights.
One of the party leaders, Walter Riehl,
who was later a member of the Nazi party during
WW2, even ‘led [young youths] into the streets
to fight physically against Czech immigrant
workers’ in 1908 in the Sudetens. Therefore,
as stated by Wiskemann, ironically, ‘Bohemia
was the cradle of German National Socialism.’
With that said, the Czechoslovak Nazis had far
less success than their German counterparts, and
at most, they only managed to get 3.5% of the vote
in Czechoslovakia. In fact, other German parties
in Czechoslovakia blamed them for hindering
their progress toward ethnic equality within
the country. However, the Czechoslovak Nazis had
very strong regional backing, with around 60,000
radical members in various Sudeten chapters and
an organised paramilitary group called Volkssport,
which was basically an exact copy of the
German Nazis Storm Detachments. Unsurprisingly,
in the early 1930s, some members of the Volkssport
were plotting with the German Nazis to overthrow
the Czechoslovak government in order to unite
Czechia with Germany. This plot was discovered,
and even though it was found to
have no actual plan of execution,
the perpetrators pled guilty to
conspiring against the state and
were jailed. Due to this trial, the whole
Czechoslovak Nazi party was banned in 1933.
The direct military threat presented by the
Czechoslovak Nazis made the Czechoslovak state
become far more nationalistic than it had been
prior. German police officers in areas which
had sizable Nazi support were deemed unreliable
and replaced with Czechoslovak police officers,
and many German ministers simply
advocating for German causes in
the parliament started to be
viewed as national traitors.
The increasing nationalism and the frequent
skirting around the minority laws by the
Czechoslovaks pushed a lot of centrist
Germans towards the more radical right,
but what really sealed the deal was the
Great Depression of the early 1930s.
Czechslovaks were mostly farmers,
while Germans were mostly artisans,
factory workers, and small business owners,
all sectors of the economy that got hit much
harder in Czechoslovakia during the great
depression. At its height, the unemployment
rate of Germans in Czechoslovakia is estimated
to be almost double that of the Czechoslovaks.
The Great Depression reached its height in
Czechoslovakia in 1933, the same year that
the Nazi party got banned and a new right-wing
German party was formed, the Sudeten German Party,
which had multiple names throughout its history,
but we’ll just call it the Sudeten German Party
for simplicity. Almost all of the former
supporters and members of the Czechoslovak
Nazi party joined the Sudeten German party;
it also gained a lot of new unemployed German
supporters who were disgruntled with the current
status quo and wanted to see a drastic change.
Unlike the Nazi party, the Sudeten German Party
officially adopted a less radical platform. The
key word here is ‘officially’. The leader of the
party Konrad Henlein officially stated that he was
only fighting for equal rights for the Germans
in Czechoslovakia and that he only wanted more
autonomy for the Germans within Czechoslovakia
based on either a federal system or a Swiss
canton system. This less radical official stance
was because much of the Sudeten German voting
base at this point didn’t want to break away from
Czechoslovakia, nor were many of them politically
fascist. A British foreign office official
stationed in Prague in 1934 ‘had come to the
conclusion based on information available that a
demand to revise the borders did not particularly
resonate amongst Czech Germans.’ That is why the
Sudeten German Party officially adopted a far less
radical agenda. While secretly, the Sudeten German
party promoted fascist ideology and was even
funded by the German Nazis. Henlein, before the
Sudeten German Party was founded, even stated that
‘We declare war to the death upon liberalism even
behind the disguise of the cult of personality.
Disciplined mass unities rule the present-
Fascist, the Heimwehr, the Hitler movement. For
men wish to be led in manly fashion … We all know
that an un-German parliamentarism, an un-German
party system, which divides our people into
inorganic parts, will and must break down at some
point.’ Henlein said this before the Sudeten Party
was formed, but he never changed his ideology
since then. He simply just officially presented
a far less radical political agenda to avoid
getting banned, but secretly he was financed by
the Nazis and held the same beliefs as the Nazis.
Despite the backroom fascism of the German
Sudeten party, the breaches of the minority
laws by nationalistic Czechoslovaks, the rise
of Nazi Germany and fascism across Europe,
the large unemployed rate in German areas,
and the less radical official stand of the
Sudeten German party, resulted in the
party winning a major political victory
in the 1935 election. It gained over 60% of the
German vote, which was 15% of the total vote,
tying it with the Agrarian Party for the largest
party in the Czechoslovak parliament. It, however,
still ended up being in the opposition because
various parties set up a coalition government.
Once in the parliament, the Sudeten German
party, despite its campaign promises, became
increasingly fascist and irredentist. New German
Nazi propaganda started to be distributed in the
Sudetenland, and new paramilitary groups were
organised. In response, the Czechoslovaks became
increasingly nationalistic and banned a couple
of German fascist newspapers and imprisoned their
publishers. Political extremism in Czechoslovakia
became a positive feedback loop, with both sides
becoming ever more radical in their actions
and both blaming the other for escalating it.
Despite all this, a British historian writing
in 1937 stated, ‘Today Czechoslovakia,
almost alone among European countries east of
Switzerland, enjoys a genuine parliamentary
system of government. There is a franchise which
is equal for all nationalities, a ballot which is
genuinely secret, reasonable liberty of agitation
and propaganda, and, what is equally important,
a Parliament whose decisions really count. The
minorities of Czechoslovakia (unlike those of
Hungary or Yugoslavia) are allowed to form
political parties, the conditions regarding
which do not discriminate between the different
nationalities, and all of them have, in fact,
availed themselves of this privilege. Their
leaders, including those of the Magyar nationalist
party, can travel freely about the country, and
even abroad; can make electoral propaganda, and
when they speak in Parliament or Senate at Prague
will be heard with due decorum, and not greeted,
as they might be in neighboring capitals, with
ink-pots, rotten eggs, or revolver-bullets.’
Despite Czechoslovakia maintaining its democratic
character when other countries around it were
becoming ever more authoritarian,
the writing was on the wall. Sudeten
German paramilitary groups, trained,
funded, and supported by Nazi Germany,
started to undertake ever more drastic
terrorist attacks. With that said,
there were Sudeten German groups that were
horrified by the violence and fascism and
protested against the Nazis and the Sudeten
Party and worked with Czechoslovak institutions,
but at this point, the majority of the Sudeten
Germans either kept quiet or supported the Nazis.
In 1938 Nazi Germany initiated a coup
attempt in Czechoslovakia through the
Sudeten German Party which proved unsuccessful.
However, it did convince the world powers,
at the behest of Nazi Germany, that they had
to intervene and resolve the ethnic issues
in Czechoslovakia or risk an all-out war in
Central Europe. This intervention resulted,
in accordance with the Western appeasement
policy, in the Munich Agreement. Uniting
the Sudeten Germans with Germany. This
pretty much crippled Czechoslovakia,
as the country became extremely unstable
politically, economically, and, most
importantly, defensively. Therefore, its takeover
by Nazi Germany a year later was inevitable.
---------------------- WW2
Occupation-----------------
While Slovakia became a willing de
facto puppet state of Nazi Germany,
Czechia was incorporated into the German
state as the protectorate of Bohemia and
Moravia. The entire Czech industry and people
were mobilised for the German war effort,
and by 1943, any civilian industry in Czechia was
prohibited. All Czech schools had to teach German,
Czech universities were closed, and Czech
intellectuals were imprisoned, shot, or sent to
labour camps. Land owned primarily by Jews, the
state, and enemies of the Reich was confiscated
and allocated for future German settlement.
A Czech Moscow informant remarked in 1941,
‘To date some hundred shot. Thousands in
concentration camps ... Nazis shooting
on the streets as if on hunting grounds. The
complete plundering of the country is horrible.’
Of course, just like in any other Nazi-occupied
country, there were Czech Nazi collaborators,
but there was also a Czech underground
resistance which managed to kill Reinhard
Heydrich, the principal architect
of the holocaust. In retaliation,
the Nazis destroyed two Czech villages suspected
of helping the Czech resistance. The Nazis also
instituted a crackdown on the personal
liberties of the Czechs in order to stifle
any future resistance. Thousands of Czechs
during this time were imprisoned, executed,
and sent to labour camps or, more rarely, death
camps. It is estimated that around 36-55,000
Czechs died in concentration camps during
the protectorate. All this was, of course,
happening alongside the holocaust, which saw
over ¾ of the Czech Jewish population killed.
When it came to the overall German plans for
Czechia, they can probably be best summarised by
Hitler himself, who stated that ‘assimilation of
a greater part of the Czech people is possible for
historical and racial reasons, provided that those
Czechs who are racially useless and hostile to the
Reich will be eliminated.’ How many Czechs were
deemed racially viable for assimilation varied
throughout the time of the protectorate, but it
was usually given somewhere between 50 to 60%.
The lives of Czechs in the protectorate can
hardly be called good, but because the Nazis
deemed much of the Czech population as racially
viable for assimilation, the life of an average
Czech under Nazi rule was often better
than that of Poles or Ukrainians. In fact,
the Czech population even grew between 1939 and
1945, which can’t be said about Poland or Ukraine.
When it came to Slovakia, because it had a
collaboration government, it did not see any harsh
treatment by the Nazis until the unsuccessful
1944 Slovak National Uprising and even then,
many of the Nazi-organised executions
in Slovakia, like those in Kremnička,
targeted mostly Jews and Roma people, not
Slovaks. In December of 1944, out of the estimated
13,000 people arrested by the Germans in Slovakia,
10,000 were Jews. Also, most of these operations
were still done in collaboration with the Slovak
Fascists, with the Hlinka Guard and the rest. The
quote ‘German’ murders in the towns of Kremnicka
and Nemecká were done by both German and Fascist
Slovak soldiers. Hlinka Guard was even known to
be more ruthless than the Germans. For example,
they would execute disarmed Slovak partisans
that the Germans released. And don’t even get
me started on the Slovak National Uprising.
It was a disorganised mess full of racists and
antisemites. A Jewish doctor of German-Slovak
heritage called Klein tried to work with the
partisans because he deemed it better than
working with the Germans, but he reported that
‘Those Slovak [partisans] antisemites obviously
wanted to kill me immediately … but then the
Russians stepped up and said, don’t do it, we
do not have another doctor.’ Klein later added,
‘Those Slovak partisans were actually fascist
elements who had ended up there for all kinds
of opportunistic reasons and could not
handle the fact that the Jews were once
again partners and held equal rights.’ Of
course, not everyone in the Slovak National
Uprising was antisemitic and racist as it was
a very disorganised and heterogeneous movement,
as rebellions often are; but my god,
today’s official Slovak narrative of the
National Uprising and of the Slovak Fascist State
itself, is extremely false. Anyways, where was I?
Ou yes, in general, the treatment of
Slovaks by the German Nazis was fairly mild,
and many Slovaks, especially of the Hlinka guard,
were just as much to blame for war
atrocities in Slovakia as the Germans were.
----------------------- ‘The Final
Solution’----------------------------
Even before the war had ended, the
Czechoslovak government in exile
and the Polish government in exile tried to
convince the Allied powers of the necessity
of the post-war expulsion of Germans from
Poland and Czechoslovakia. During this time,
the Sudeten German Social Democratic party
was also exiled from Czechoslovakia and tried
to work with the Czechoslovak government
in exile but to no avail. At this point,
most Czechoslovaks viewed the Czechoslovak
Germans as the sole reason for the pre-war
downfall of the country and, therefore, to try
to prevent any such problems in the future,
their solution was the total expulsion of the
entire German population from Czechoslovakia.
Initially, Britain and the US were reluctant
to agree to a full-scale expulsion, but the
USSR wholeheartedly supported it, so when the Red
Army liberated Czechoslovakia between March and
May of 1945, it did not stand in the way of the
Czechoslovak government starting the expulsion
of the Germans. The Czechoslovak government
implemented a so-called ‘collective guilt’,
which stipulated that every German who did not
actively oppose the Nazis should be treated as
a collaborator and, therefore, expelled from the
country if not outright killed. The Czechoslovak
decrees, known as the Benes decrees, did
stipulate that known anti-fascist Germans,
German Czechoslovak collaborators, and German
victims of Nazi aggression would be spared,
but in reality, in the chaos of the post-war
expulsion, these nuances were often ignored.
The Czechoslovak rhetoric around the expulsion
of the Germans was ironically very familiar. The
Czechoslovak National Socialist party declared
that the primary task was ‘to clean out the
republic as a whole and completely of Germans
… everyone of us must help in the cleansing of
the homeland.’ Edvard Benes, the president
of Czechoslovakia, called for the ‘final
solution of the German question’, and he also
stated that the few Germans that would remain
‘would be settled among the Czech population’
and ‘assimilated’. Czechoslovak officers even
forced the Germans to wear white armbands marked
with the letter N for Nemec, meaning German.
The first few months after the red army liberated
Czechoslovakia were the most violent and chaotic.
The only state body that could enforce the
laws were Czechoslovak militias that fought
for the partisans or the red army or were
recently recruited from the liberated lands
of Czechoslovakia; and many of these hastily
organised militias lacked officers, training,
and discipline and often acted more like roaming
bands of barbarians than an official state organ.
‘These armed fighters drew no distinctions
between anti-fascist Germans, plain farmers,
or Henleinist sympathisers. In a
paroxysm of violence that shocked
even experienced Soviet tank commanders and
political officers, Czechs beat up Germans,
shot at them … and showed them no mercy. People
were randomly killed, and villages were torched
and burned to the ground. Germans were hung
by their heels from trees, doused in petrol,
and set on fire … Czech militia rampaged through
towns and villages, shooting Germans at will.’
In Usti nad Labem an accidental munition explosion
was erroneously blamed on the German population.
In retaliation, the Czech militia and citizens
rounded up, shot, and bayoneted some Germans while
others, including Women and Children, were thrown
off the bridge into the Elbe River and drowned. In
Přerov, Carpathian Germans were passing through
in a train when the train was suddenly stopped
by a Czechoslovak militia. 71 men, 120 women
and 74 children were taken out of the train,
marched to the top of a nearby hill and were
forced to dig their own graves. After which,
they were all shot. When the commanding
officer was later questioned why he also
killed the children, he replied with, ‘Čo
som mal s nimi robiť, keď sme im postrieľali
rodičov?’ (What was I supposed to do with
them when we already shot their parents?).
Germans that weren’t killed were often at
gunpoint forced to leave their homes. ‘The
Germans were given very little time to pack up
and leave, sometimes no more than fifteen minutes,
and they were allowed to take only the barest
minimum of things with them. They lost their
livelihoods and jobs, and they were threatened
with violence by the new rulers if they refused
to vacate their homes, which were, in any
case, open territory for Czech plundering.’
However, the infrastructure didn’t allow
for a simultaneous deportation of millions
of Germans living in postwar Czechoslovakia, so
the Germans who had to wait to be deported were
sent to Czechoslovak labour camps. These
labour camps were all over Czechoslovakia,
and some of them were literally just repurposed
Nazi labour camps (Camp Teresin). The condition
in these camps was horrid, and many Germans died
of disease, starvation, or committed suicide.
These camps were more numerous in today’s Czechia,
but they also existed in Slovakia. For example,
in the labour camp near Pezinok, several
Carpathian Germans, who were taken from their
homes during summer and therefore didn’t take
winter clothes with them, died of frostbite in
the winter when the guards refused to give them
any firewood or extra clothes. The Czechoslovak
sentiments towards the Germans were made clear
at a different labour camp in Budejovice were
the commanding officer wrote the words ‘Eye for
an eye, tooth for a tooth’ on the entrance gate.
Some Germans didn’t even make it to the labour
camps. In the infamous Death March of Brno, the
entire remaining German population of the city,
roughly 30,000 people, were forced out of their
homes and beaten mercilessly while they marched
to a labour camp in Pohořelice. German estimates
put the death toll at around 2000 people during
the march and around another 2000 in the camp
itself. Czech estimates state roughly 1000 deaths
during the march and another 1000 in the camp.
Women, in particular, were treated
extremely poorly in these labour camps.
‘As is often the case in ethnic cleansing,
the women were generally separated from
the men and sexually abused and exploited in
violent and obscene ways. They were constantly
called svine (“pigs”) and nacistické kurvy
(“nazi whores”) and sometimes were stripped
and beaten merely for the entertainment of the
guards.’ A woman who survived the Czechoslovak
labour camps later recalled, ‘Every time of the
day we, women, were raped and our shirts torn
from our bodies’ another woman added, ‘What
all that happened during the raping is hard
for me to talk about. If one would imagine the
worst, then it remains far behind the truth.’
With all this happening, it should not
be surprising that the suicide rate among
the Czechoslovak Germans was extremely high.
General Serov, documenting the refugee crisis
happening in Germany caused by the expulsion
of Germans from Czechoslovakia, wrote, ‘Daily,
up to 5,000 Germans arrive in Germany from
Czechoslovakia, the majority of whom are women,
old folks, and children. With their futures
ruined and having no hope for anything better,
many of them end their lives by suicide,
cutting their wrists.’ On a single day in July,
in one refugee camp alone, around 71
Sudeten Germans committed suicide.
By August of 1945, the Allied
powers finally agreed they would
allow the expulsion of the Germans from
Czechoslovakia, Poland, and Hungary,
despite the fact that it was already
happening for months. They declared that,
‘The Three Governments, having considered
the question in all its aspects,
recognise that the transfer to Germany of
German populations, or elements thereof,
remaining in Poland, Czechoslovakia and
Hungary, will have to be undertaken. They
agree that any transfers that take place should
be effected in an orderly and humane manner.’
With the USA and Britain focusing heavily
on the ‘orderly and humane manner’ part of
this declaration. After this declaration, the
wild roaming bands of Czechoslovak militias
indiscriminately purging Germans and the sudden
expulsion of whole cities’ German populations,
like in Brno, ceased to exist, as the
Czechoslovak government finally created
better systems for a more orderly conduct of
the expulsion. This is not to say that human
rights violations didn’t happen, but they were on
a much smaller scale than in the preceding months.
By 1948, out of the roughly 3.1 million
Germans living in Czechoslovakia,
only around 165,000-200,000 remained, the
majority of them from mixed-ethnic families.
Despite the Czechoslovak decrees stating that
German anti-fascists, German Jews, and German
Czechoslovak collaborators could stay, this often
was ignored. After the war, well over a thousand
Czechoslovak Jews filed complaints to the United
Nations for being illegally deported. People like
Hilda Elsner, who had to do forced labour for the
Nazis and whose father was killed in a death camp,
were deported by the Czechoslovaks simply because
they didn’t speak Czechoslovak. In another
incident of illegal deportation of anti-fascist
Germans in Pezinok, a Czechoslovak official
stated, ‘v Ríši môžu preukázať cenné služby, a u
nás bude aspoň menší počet Nemcov’ (‘in the Reich
they can provide valuable services and we will at
least end up with a smaller number of Germans’).
The facts that some Czechoslovak Germans
actively protested against the German Sudeten
Party in the 1930s or that, during the war,
the Sudeten German Social Democrats in exile
tried to collaborate with the Czechoslovak
government, or that there were plenty of
German Jews or anti-fascist Germans that resisted
the Nazis, were all ignored. For the most part,
if you only spoke German, you were
expelled from the country, if not worse.
All the wealth which Germans were forced to
leave behind was redistributed to Czechoslovaks,
and Czechoslovak colonisations of
the now-depopulated areas were highly
promoted with free land giveaways, tax cuts, and
business handouts. Despite this vigorous promotion
of colonisation by the state, the depopulated
areas still suffered extreme labour shortages,
and in certain areas, Hungarians from southern
Czechoslovakia had to be forcibly resettled to
shore up these labour shortages. Due to the
lack of human capital, production in these
depopulated areas drastically fell. In the Little
Carpathians, there were wine and lumber shortages
because it was the Germans who were winemakers
and lumberjacks, and the Czechoslovaks that were
given these new jobs weren’t trained. Factories,
which relied heavily on trained labour, suffered
the most. As Gerlach points out, ‘In many cases
Germans possessed skills and experience vital to
sustain production in local factories’, experience
that was now completely gone from the country.
Higher skilled jobs in the Sudetenland, like
finances, saw a 26% decrease, health care 21%,
and the number of people with university degrees
fell by 22.2%. By killing and deporting most
of its German population, Czechoslovakia
drastically hindered its post-war economy.
The deportation of almost the entire
German population of Czechoslovakia,
whether we like it or not, was purely an act
of the Czechoslovak people and our government.
-------Conclusion------
The history of the German-speaking population
of Czechoslovakia is very complicated,
and in this video, we touched upon only its last
chapter. It was a remnant of a medieval past
when ethnic affiliations did not matter as much,
resulting in the creation of multiethnic kingdoms
like that of Bohemia and Austria. However,
as nationalism took hold in Europe and the
idea of an ethnocentric nation-state became
the norm- gradually increasing nationalistic
fanaticism developed on both sides, which
culminated ‘in one of the largest waves of
forced migration in history’. With no one ever
stopping to ask whether an ‘eye for an eye’
won’t leave the whole country blind.
Jelikož jsem měl k videu slovenské
titulky a citoval jsem v něm několik slovenských
pasáží, rozhodl jsem se pro zábavu udělat outro
v češtině. Rozhodně mám divný přízvuk, ale hej,
alespoň mě to přijde vtipný. Každopádně doufám,
že se vám video líbilo a dozvěděli jste se něco
nového. Samozřejmě jsem o tomto tématu mohl říct
mnohem více než se vešlo do tohoto videa, takže
pokud se chcete o tématu dozvědět více, podívejte
se na bibliografii, link je v připnutém komentáři.
Tohle byla velmi těžká a kontroverzní téma,
a jsem si jistý, že o tom nedostanu žádné
rozzlobené e-maily. /s Pravděpodobně
dostanu více rozzlobených e-mailů o tomto outru,
který se snažím udělat v češtině. Také si nejsem
jistý, zda je toto video zmonetizovano. Musel jsem
upravit určité části videa, abych se ho pokusil
zmonetisovat, ale pokud stále není zmonetizovano,
zvažte prosím podporu mé práce na Patreonu nebo
zde na YouTube. Bez
této finanční podpory bych nemohl mluvit o těchto
citlivějších a kontroverznějších tématech. Jako
vždy zakončím poděkováním svým Patreonům, zejména
Patreonům na úrovni deity: Rohanovi, Carftymu
kriminalistovi a Bryanu Lafatovi.
(Since I had Slovak subtitles for
the video and quoted several Slovak passages in
it, for fun, I decided to make the outro in Czech
(to mix it up a bit). I definitely have a weird
accent, but hey, at least I find it funny. Anyway,
I hope you enjoyed the video and learned something
new. Of course, I could have said a lot more about
this topic than would have fit in this one video,
so if you want to learn more about the topic,
check out the bibliography, the link is in the
pinned comment. This was a very difficult and
controversial topic and I'm certain I won't get
any angry emails about it. /s I'll probably get
more angry emails about this outro that I'm trying
to do in Czech. I'm also not sure if this video
is monetized. I had to edit certain parts of the
video to try to monetize it, but if it's still not
monetized, please consider supporting my work on
Patreon or here on YouTube. Without this financial
support, I would not be able to talk about these
more sensitive and controversial topics. As
always, I'll end with thanking my Patreons,
especially the deity tier Patreons: Rohan,
Carfty Kriminalist, and Bryan Lafat.)
Ahhh,
I had way too much fun doing that :D
Pictures in the video were taken from